Judy I saw a quote from you somewhere
where it said never give up or stop
dreaming you may have to do a lot less
meaningful work along the way to sustain
yourself but to have to hold on to your
dreams and I think that's a boat that a
lot of indie people whether it's music
whatever in can you tell us about some
of the times that you have to do some
less meaningful work and how you kept
sort of that prize of what you really
wanted in the back of your mind to keep
you going well the phrase less
meaningful is as is relative because it
may be less meaningful to you
artistically and soulfully but there's
another part of the business there are
several parts of the business that you
have to take care of and one of them is
to learn how to sustain yourself
financially how to make a living in the
business and what it takes to do that
and the things that are most satisfying
to your heart and soul are not the
things that are generally going to bring
you the most money so I have a times
taken jobs on television shows mostly
where either
I wasn't enthralled with the subject
matter or it wasn't something that
represented how I felt about things but
nevertheless there was a lot to learn
from it and just learning how to operate
in that world learning what it takes to
make a product get to market and what it
takes to sustain a product these are all
valuable lessons so when I would go into
one of these projects I would look for
the thing in it that I didn't know that
I would learn from it and on that level
I could always find a way to enjoy what
I was doing sometimes it would get to me
after a long time because being a woman
director what was offered to me a lot of
times was more reality oriented things
and some of them had
some subject matter that I really wasn't
something I wanted to deal with you know
sometimes it would get to me and if it
got to me too much
I'd walk I'd say you know this is not
for me anymore
but finding ways to learn something on
every project that I was on getting
something out of it making more
connections in the world advancing my
career in other ways those were things
that I learned from having to do things
that weren't from my heart
you